this year's Nobel Peace Prize is being
shared by three champions of Human
Rights the jail Belarusian rights
activist Alice bialytsky Russia's
Memorial organization and Ukraine's
Center for civil liberties The Joint
award highlights the significance of
Civil Society for peace and democracy
the most highly anticipated announcement
in a week of awards at the stroke of 11
in Oslo the chair of Norway's Nobel
committee ended the speculation
this year's Peace Prize is awarded to
Human Rights Advocate Alice biology from
Belarus
the Russian human rights organization
Memorial
and the Ukrainian human rights
organization Center for civil liberties
the committee said it was recognizing
three champions of human values in a
region Rife with repression and fearless
they have made
an outstanding effort to document war
crimes human rights abuses and the abuse
of power
together they demonstrate the
significance of Civil Society for peace
and democracy
Alice bialyutsky has been a leader of
the Democracy movement in Belarus since
the mid-1980s he was detained following
anti-government protests in 2020 and
remains in jail without trial the
committee called for the 60 year old's
immediate release
Ukraine's Center for civil liberties has
been active for more than a decade
following Russia's invasion of Ukraine
the group has worked tirelessly to
document war crimes against civilians
the memorial NGO has its roots in the
Soviet Union
in Russia it continued to track human
rights abuses and the fate of political
prisoners but it was dissolved late last
year as part of the kremlin's ever
tightening Crackdown on descent
polish the Nobel committee says the
prize was not a direct message to the
Russian president for most though it's
another stinging rebuke for the
repressive regime of Vladimir Putin
which also happens to fall on his 70th
birthday
now DW correspondent Nick Connelly joins
us now from Kiev and on the line from
bond is ZW Russia analyst Roman
goncharenko Nick let's start with you
the only individual who was awarded is
the human rights Advocate Alice
bialytsky who is an evolution prison a
prison uh right now could you tell us
more about him
I think his biography really stands for
the history of modern Belarus this is
someone who started off as a dissident
in his student years in the 1980s while
the Soviet Union still existed who has
been in out of in and out of prison
routinely since Belarus gained
independence in the early 90s and uh
whose organization vishna is crucial to
helping families helping loved ones find
out where their uh their their closest
relatives and friends are often you know
arrests in Belarus happened without much
warning without any proper procedure and
there's obviously been a lot of
harassment of journalists but also of
anyone standing up for their civil
rights down the decades and that's
obviously was something brought into
real shop focus in 2020 when you had
those Mass protests in Belarus hundreds
of thousands of people's people going
out to protest and lots of people just
disappearing for days on end so an
organization like his vishna really
crucial there he's been in jail since
2021 and this is obviously a very clear
signal from the prize committee that
Belarus is not forgotten for all the
stuff going on in Russia and in Ukraine
this is still very much on the agenda
uh Rowan let's talk about the Russian
organization Memorial and why do they
deserve this prize
well it is it is the price that I get
the price now because they were
nominated many times it is the most the
most famous the most renowned Russian
human rights organization uh founded in
the 80s
um a child of perestroika if you wish
the time when Russia was Soviet Union at
that time was open open for democracy
and um at the core of its activity was
studying the dark times of the Soviet
Union and the third is the great Terror
by the Soviet dictator's Italian and in
that respect it is also a signal to
current Russian President Vladimir Putin
who adores Stalin and trying to
implement some of stunning methods in
current Russia and also in this war in
Ukraine against Ukraine and that is why
it is a very symbolic decision by the
Nobel Prize committee to show that it is
important to remember the crimes of the
past it is important to prevent them in
the future and now in these days
uh Nick back to you uh can you tell us
more about the third recipient the
Ukrainian human rights organization
Center for civil liberties please
I think it wouldn't uh you know they
wouldn't be offended if I said that this
is certainly an organization that is a
lot less prominent in Ukraine than both
uh Elizabeth organization and Memorial
are in their respective countries yes
this is almost that has been operating
for years now has been looking to kind
of check keep a check on what the
government and the government's judicial
organs are doing most recently since the
most recent phase of this Russian
aggression against Ukraine it's been
documenting war crimes against civilians
in Russian occupied Ukraine something
that obviously has to be done quickly
and following all the standards if those
uh bits of evidence are going to be used
in potential war crimes prosecutions but
certainly Ukraine is not a country that
has the same issues with freedom of
speech and with uh judicial kind of
abuses as Belarus and Russia do I think
this is really about the Optics at a
time where Russia is attacking Ukraine
where Belarus is being used by Russia to
attack Ukraine at the Nobel Prize
committee wants to include a Ukrainian
organization in that three uh kind of
group that that triple group of winners
uh Rowan in the light of what Nick just
said there does this mean that the Nobel
committee uh is kind of taking aim in a
way at Vladimir Putin on his birthday
well I think it's a it's a side effect
it's not the number one aim of the Nobel
crime price committee to to give a sign
uh to believe me Putin on his birthday
but it is important that all three
countries are represented it just he
said the Russia is Waging War against
Ukraine using Belarusian territory and
um it was important also to to take a
Ukrainian to to give this award also to
a Ukrainian organization a human rights
organization I think what at the core of
this is
um it is it is a it is a message to
Vladimir Putin that this war will be
over someday and uh the crimes that are
committed now will be investigated by
these organizations and others of course
but this stand out and this is this is
the their time will come I think this is
one of the messages of this uh of this
day the time will come when the crimes
will be investigated and it is very
important to have independent
organizations like vyasana in Belarus
alike Memorial
um in Russia or like that Center for
civil liberties in Ukraine they are
working now as we speak to collect very
important data which was the latest
Target at the court
CW's Russia analyst Roman gone there and
uh correspondent Nick Connelly reporting
from Keith thank you both very much